[موسيقى]
موسكو احدى اكثر عواصم العالم تحصينا عاده
ما تحمي القوى الكبرى مراكز صنع قرارها
بتحصينات متعدده المستويات تحيط روسيا
عاصمتها بدرع صاروخيه لاعتراض اي هجمات
بصواريخ نوويه او استراتيجيه وحول موسكو
تتوزع منظومات دفاعيه ابرزها منظومه اس
400 التي يصفها خبراء عسكريون بانها من
بين الافضل ضمن منظومات الدفاع الجوي وهي
نظام متنقل قادر على كشف الاهداف الجويه
على بعد 400 كيلومتر والتصدي لثمانين هدفا
منها في وقت واحد عن طريق توجيه صاروخين
ارض جو لكل هدف منظومه اس 300 وهي مصممه
للتصدي للطائرات المهاجمه والصواريخ طويله
المدى مثل صواريخ كروز ويمكنها اعتراض 24
طائره او 16 صاروخا باليستي حتى مسافه 250
كيلومترا في وقت واحد
تحمي روسيا مواقعها الحيويه والحساسه
بمنظومات دفاع قصيره المدى كمنظومه بانسر
اس واحد التي توصف بانها حاميه سماء موسكو
وهي قادره على رصد وتدمير الاهداف الجويه
على مدى 20 كيلومترا تمتلك بانسر اس واحد
12 صاروخا وكذلك مدفعين اوتوماتيكيين
يستخدمان ضد الذخائر النفاثه والصواريخ
والى جانب دفاعاتها الصاروخيه تتخذ روسيا
اجراءات لحمايه قلب موسكو وتحديدا مقر
القياده السياسيه للبلاد الكريم تعطل
السلطات الروسيه انظمه الملاحه الجويه
والارضيه وكافه الاتصالات خلال تحركات
الرئيس والصف الاول من القياده ومنذ بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا تحضر السلطات الروسيه
تحليق الطائرات المسيره بكافه انواعها في
سماء موسكو ارضا وجوا وبحرا وحتى في
العالم الافتراضي تضرب روسيا طوقا يقيها
اي هجمات معاديه معطيات تفرض تساؤلا بشان
كيف تجاوز الطائرات مسيره هذا الطوق ووصلت
الى قلب روسيا ومركز قرارها